por ahora no habrá restablecimiento de
la normalidad democrática en túnez así
lo confirmó el presidente de caixa side
un mes después de tomar una decisión que
provocaría críticas de la comunidad
internacional y también apoyo de
sectores importantes de la población
este es el comunicado oficial
el presidente de la republica caixa jet
emitió una orden presidencial ampliando
las medidas excepcionales esas medidas
fueron implementadas por caixa site el
25 de julio cuando anunció la suspensión
del parlamento y la destitución del
primer ministro
wen la primera decisión es congelar
todos los poderes del parlamento la
constitución no permite su disolución
pero no obstaculice la suspensión de
todas sus actividades
partidos políticos y organizaciones
denunciaron las medidas así como parte
de la comunidad internacional
mientras muchos tunecinos exasperados
con su clase política recibieron con
entusiasmo la decisión del presidente
con respecto a esta decisión es la
primera vez en mi vida que escucho a un
jefe de estado tomar una decisión
correcta
hemos recuperado nuestro país es la
primera vez que salgo a la calle a
celebrar en paralelo el jefe de estado
inició una purga anticorrupción con
arrestos y prohibiciones de viaje- a
magistrados diputados y empresarios lo
que suscitó preocupaciones de un
retroceso de las libertades en el país
caixa side aún no ha designado un nuevo
gobierno ni desvelado su hoja de ruta un
mes después la confusión sigue en el
país mientras el presidente mantiene
todo el poder hasta nueva orden